what is going on everyone's a buzz on  the internet freaking out about um the  book in the in the  erica put it in the trash what this is  classic housewives everybody's in for it  that's why they're dialogue on oh my god  sorry it is it's a jogging out of a show  i can't believe how many people are  invested into everything we do i mean it  is a cult i mean it's crazy with 8 000  spin-offs this is like it's taken all  over the world  um you know what i posted a clip that  was in the trailer of our new season  and uh i guess erica felt a certain way  about it clearly clearly and uh i wish  her well  the look says it all that's high road  with a i see you  you should be a housewife come come on  true  ironically i used to love trauma and now  i am as far away from it as possible